well look after all the sleeves and all
the failure it's clear that this Tory
government is now collapsing and Tory
cabinet ministers have been cheerleaders
for Johnson throughout this sorry Saga
they backed him when he broke the law
they backed him when he lied they backed
him when he mocked the sacrifices of the
British people so they have been
complicit as he has disgraced his office
and let down his country and frankly if
they had a shred of Integrity they would
have gone months ago the Tory party is
corrupted and changing one man at the
top won't fix it we need a real change
of government and a fresh start for
Britain just on that though you know
many people are concerned about big
issues because the living crisis or
Ukraine many people say this is not a
time actually to change the government
this is the time for political stability
well there's anything but political
stability this government is collapsing
um and the Tory cabinet members have
been backing Boris Johnson through this
the Tory party is corrupted and we need
not just a change at the top of the Tory
party we need a change of government and
a fresh start for our country so we can
actually address those big issues that
are undoubtedly out there so if the
Prime Minister said the way out of this
for him is to call the general election
he wants to go to the public you would
support that well look he's not fit to
be prime minister he's not fit to govern
the country
um that is Dawning on many people across
the conservative party but they have to
reflect on the fact that they have
backed him for months and months and
months and resigning today
it means nothing against their
complicity for all those months when
they should have seen him before he what
he was they knew who he was we need a
change of government
does that mean an election you would
support a general election if one was
was called in the next couple of weeks
yes we need a fresh start for Britain we
need a change of government and this
government is collapsing the Tory party
is corrupted and changing one man at the
top of the Tory party won't make any
difference he won't fix the problems
let's have a fresh start for Britain
let's have a real change of government